bonjour bonjour et bienvenue sur
diagonale tv spéciale championnats du
monde car c'est 90 aujourd'hui on va
voir la septième partie de ce match tout
à fait extraordinaire alors avant on
arrivait dans cette ct ok on va quand
même faire un peu tu reçois 6e puisque
on avait oublié de vous parler d'un
point quand même important dans la
sixième donc je vous renvoie quand même
à l'assise par des eaux pour voir toute
la partie mais il ya pas moins qu'il
fallait absolument revoir c'est dans
cette position que j'ai oublié de
d'analyser en détail
bien entendu il y avait une gaffe de
carsen puisqu'ici il joue au roi des
deux au lieu de jouer le coup roi des
huns voyez où on voit pas trop la
différence mais vous allez voir pourquoi
roi des huns la variante qu'on va voir
ne marche pas je vous laisserai
découvrir très vite comment et pourquoi
après roi des deux en fait il ya une
astuce d'un ordre qui lui permettait de
prendre avantage puisqu'ils pouvaient
jouer cavalier prend que cinq tours est
attaqué par le cavalier par la tour si
on fait ont conquis à lyon perd la tour
donc il faut prendre avec les blancs et
pas le choix parce qu'on a perdu un pion
faut d'abord échangé puis on se dit on
prend on va gagner le cavalier mais ça
marche pas on peut pas reprendre le
cavalier puisqu'il ya cavalli prend ses
quartiers chez cora et donc il faut
rester au contact essayer d'aller
prendre ce cavalier et les blancs
puisque 6 en cadeau pour prendre tôt on
prendra le cavalier donc on va jouer roi
des trois mais ça marche toujours pas
évidemment heureux même pas 1 5 puisque
échec puisqu'il ya tout reprendre mais
aussi après avoir regardé cavaliers b 2
échecs et par miracle ça marche très
bien pour les noirs puisque le roi blanc
ne peut pas aller attaquer ce cavalier à
cause des deux pions blancs
donc on est obligé maintenant de jouer
roi eux deux et après tout reprend ici
les blancs peuvent jouer par exemple g3
est simplement bon effectivement ils
n'ont pas pu perdu ce plan ils vont on
va gagner le plus 1,6 mais regardez il
ya deux pions contre 2 ici et là trois
pions contre 2 bon les blancs la paire
de fou donc il aurait pu essayer
peut-être de faire nul quand même mais
c'est quand même avantage noir avec
belles possibilités de gains un gros
avantage et anand aurait donc pu prendre
le dessus dans cette sixième partie et
au lieu de la paire de l'aurait pu la
gagner
ce qui aurait changé le cours du
championnat du monde bien entendu
évidemment les joueurs font toujours des
erreurs il ya eu des fautes aussi dans
les matchs kasparov karpov
il ya toujours dans les championnats du
monde des fautes y avait pas de faute
évidemment il y aurait pas deux
victoire donc on va voir maintenant tout
de suite cette septième partie qui on va
le voir est tout à fait extraordinaire
car scène à deux nouveaux les blancs
pourquoi parce que on est arrivé dans la
deuxième moitié du match qui en douze
parties donc après les six premières
parties on a six nouvelles parties et on
inverse le sens des couleurs donc que
carson avait les blancs en deuxième dans
la première moitié du match cette fois
il aura les blancs en premier donc il a
deux fois les blancs 6e ils avaient des
blancs maintenant ils allaient blanc et
après ce sera bien sûr à un homme
d'avoir les blancs jusqu'à la fin du
match ce qui nous permet une fin de
championnat du monde ce qui nous permet
de voir une pub fin de championnat du
monde tout à fait passionnante parce que
ça va être tendu et vous allez voir
cette partie est extraordinaire car
scène débute avec e4 e5
on en revient à la défense avait que 5
après avoir tenté les sicilienne ça
c'est important à noter donc il a
peut-être pris le temps d'analyser cette
variante avant d'y revenir ça arrive
aussi dans les championnats du monde ça
si on regarde les championnats du monde
parfois donc il joue une ouverture bien
préparé mais quand ils se rendent compte
qu'il ya un souci
il passe à autre chose avant d'y revenir
le temps que la préparation maison se
met un peu à jour et qui vérifie
un peu quelques quelques variantes
cavaliers ces six normales fourbe et
cinq possibilités l'espagnol mais non on
en revient à la défense de berlin qui
lui avait quand même posé de gros soucis
là car ce n avait tenté le coup des
trois rappelez-vous et détroit en
obtenant une position qui lui allait
très bien donc petit rock là l'idée
c'est de mettre la tour vers le centre
tout ça est connu depuis le match
kasparov kramnik de l'an 2000 ou kramnik
avait remis au goût du jour cette
variante face à kasparov et lui avait
posé d'énormes problèmes puisque caspar
n'avait jamais réussi à lui prendre un
point c'est une variante vous allez voir
tout à fait spéciale qui amène le jeu
d'échec d'un des contrées tout à fait
nouvelle avant ce match notamment une
ouverture ou les ordinateurs n'arrive
pas à évaluer correctement la position
puisqu'il donne un avantage important
aux blancs alors que les grands joueurs
arrivent très souvent à l'annuler avec
les noirs à faire partie nul donc les
ordinateurs sont sous quand ce qu'on
appelle l'effet d'horizon l'effet
horizon ordinateur je vous laisse
chercher ce que ça veut dire
ils sont coincés par les faits horizon
voilà qu'avec l'épreuve 4 et là regardez
les blancs bien sûr l'idée c'est qu'à
terme et on va mettre la tour en em
pourra essayer de ramasser ici sur la
colonne mais il ya mieux que ça on joue
simplement des quatre là si les blancs
prennent ici en 4 c'est toujours
possible par exemple puis on prend 1,4
eh bien on pourrait prendre le c6 par
exemple avec les blancs ou simplement
aussi jouer
des coups comme tour eu un cas va les
prendre des quatre avec avait des
menaces sur e4 ici des menaces avec un
clouage ici voilà donc c'est quand même
dangereux ainsi 17 mai c'est possible
pourquoi pas on peut le on peut
l'envisager mais c'est dangereux puisque
très vite si ce qu'allait prendre 4 par
exemple aux menaces tourin le câble est
cloué et si on le protège f3 gagne une
pièce voilà voyez que ça va très vite
indique le roi est au centre qu'il a par
ok et qu'on commence à perdre trop de
temps à prendre des pièces très
dangereux donc après des quatre les
noirs jouent plus prudent cavale et des
six c'est normal c'est classique
1 c'est plus solide on attaque le quart
les mécènes pour lui poser un souci et à
prix fous prend si les noirs prennent ce
qui est naturel par le pion b pour
amener un pion du centre il se crée
trois îlots de pions et en plus ils
n'ont pas libéré tout de suite le fou
ces huit donc pour cette raison on peut
aussi prendre du plomb des ça arrive
aussi dans l'espagnol variantes des
changes on prend comme ça et les noirs
prennent du plomb des alors le
désavantage de prendre du poids on
essaie que l'un des pions de doubler
bien sûr et après des princes 5
on a ici quatre pions du côté blanc
contre trois pions simplement du côté
nord alors que là les trois pions ici
font face aux caps sont là ces camions
ne sont pas en mobilité supérieure à ces
trois ans nombreux oui mais pas en
mobilité donc en mobilité par contre la
vente l'avantagent blanc et net côté roy
ça c'est clair
donc après des prêts à 1,5 dans cette
partie cavaliers f5
c'est le coup logique ya pa très
notamment de carrière dans bay st kitts
et mal placé puisqu'après à 4 bella il
ya plus de casse tout simplement ce
cavalier perdu alors des sicav libéré
environ b5 peut pas lancer cette peut
pas venir à sète en dessiner déjà pris
en des quatre cavaliers la dame
donc même si on échange les dames la d4
et prix puis 1-3 en c3 ou a3 et perdu
donc voyez déjà b5 s'interdit c4 ben
c'est pas terrible terrible non plus
puisqu'on peut jouer b3 qui souvent dans
l'idée des blancs c'est de jouer b3 et
four b2 donc on donne aux blancs a
profité de gagner du temps c'est pas une
bonne idée donc f5 c'est un peu la seule
case d'un prend on apprend on à des
rockets et les noirs mais on va voir que
les noirs s'en moque un peu
h3 des blancs alors pourquoi h3
ça paraît curieux parce que le foot va
pas venir un g4 qu'est ce que c'est que
ce coup bas âge 3 on prépare un
simplement le plan des blancs ont
regardé ces quatre pions contre ces
trois donc des g4 et plus tard des f4 f5
etc on va prendre de l'espace puisque
c'est là que et notre avantage c'est ici
que se passe le jeu c'est les blacks
vont attaquer avec plus d'espacé ici
maintenant le fait qu'on a échangé les
dames réduit disons-le à la force de
cette avancée il a regardé le coup
étrange 3,8 alors commenté ça c'est
difficile un peu notre coût possible
mais 3,8 bon on vient protéger
peut-être on veut éviter des cavaliers
j'ai cinq voiliers suivi de f4 on a
protégé puis après on va menacer g4 on
va prendre de l'espace
quand je vois qu'avec g5 qu'on aurait
gagné un temps sur le roi maintenant si
on joue cavalier g5 avec les blancs achi
s'est tu reviens à la maison soit 1 400
m3 et c'est c'est un pc c'est pas on a
on n'a pas pu avancer donc cavale et c3
il a regardé très joli nom c'est logique
mais il faut savoir jouer cette position
c'est pas simple h5 alors l'idée d'âge 5
qu'elle est double 1 belge commence à
empêcher éventuellement des g4 en fait
en tout cas les freiner échanger un pion
rage contre un pion de plongée et aussi
je libère potentiellement la tour en cas
des changes
voilà donc maintenant c'est mieux
puisque là le problème quand on a le
droit au centre c'est d'activer nos deux
tours c'est à dire que nos deux tours
qui sont en 8es ensuite normalement
quand on a fait le roi que le sont ce
qu'on appelle liés et elles viennent au
centre où il ya des belles colonnes bon
mais on quand on peut pas le faire on
essaie si on peut aussi
d'activer les tours via les côtés et
c'est toujours difficile puisque regarde
elle a dit si bien sûr il ya le fou fou
ici contrôler cette grande diagonale
voilà donc la c c'est un souci pour se
développer facilement
donc tout ça est logique
donc faut être quatre corps fawcett on
se développe on sort le fou on a un oeil
ici sur la case g5 ça peut être utile
tour à dire la toile on centralise une
tour faut aussi et son continue quand
même à sortir ses pièces
c'est normal caillé ces mots là c'est
l'heure de faire une première action
j'attaque le full 6 bon donc je peut
menacer entre guillemets cavaliers prend
qui on prend ce qui encore une fois là
bas a faibli quand la structure des
pions noirs bon puisqu'on aurait des
îlots de piau encore une fois on en a
trois et plus il ya de cible isolé plus
nos possibilités d'attaqué augmente
c'est les choses simples à retenir et là
regardez c'est l'heure pour le petit
couteau à 6 voilà le fait qu'on ait joué
calais 5 bouche aussi ce faux de 4
maintenant même si le calme revient aux
4 on peut envisager tout rouge et 6 par
exemple voilà et la tour et active donc
cette tour qui est difficile darné au
centre puisque le roi est au centre a
gardé le fait qu'on ait joué autour d un
fait que ben c'est très difficile de
lille et tours on peut pas sortir le roi
mais on peut activer la tour par les
côtés alors faut être prudent à cause
des menaces mais c'est tout à fait
jouable
la preuve j'ai 3 2 carsen donc j'ai
trois bains je prépare
pourquoi pas donc 3g 2 pour ramener le
roi un petit peu vers le centre d'accord
simplement c'est pas facile d'améliorer
la position ici aussi et je prépare
aussi le coup h4 pour consolider la
position non cavaliers h4 voilà parce
que si je jouais 400g trois missions il
ya cavale prend h quatre fous pranger 5
carrément non ne s'embarrasse plus donc
il donne ici le son fou un bon
garde-fous jouais pas trop pourquoi
c'est une position serré la paire de
fouet forte dans la pollution est
ouverte comme pulsion il est serré c'est
parfois les cavaliers diction meilleurs
fonds prend donc on élimine le cavalier
il préfère garder son faut aussi se
maintenant parce qu'il veut pas
permettre h4 parce que si h4 fou prend
maintenant cavalier h prend peut-être et
la tour où elle va ou parce que
maintenant si elle veut changer si c'est
elle et elle est complètement vie
séparent le pion et le pion à 5 est
faible c'est dire qu'on va jouer roger
deux tours h1 et comment défendre ça
c'est pas simple puisque si la tour et
un g6 on peut plus jouer ici donc
faudrait revenir à la maison et dans ce
cas là on ne s'activera jamais donc il
prend voilà pour ces raisons
positionnelle fo prend tout g6
maintenant c'est normal et regardez sur
h4 qui est logique je protège la
position de mon foulée 5 et j'oubliais
quasiment le coup suivant et non pas
beaucoup de coups un jeu peut même pas
jouer tour des huit pour proposer un
échange de tours qu'est ce qu'elle fout
donc a pas vraiment de groupe ça cette
position le roi a si bien et suit ça
améliore rien donc les blancs le temps
de jouer des coups il faut faire quelque
chose donc faut quand même parce que là
les blancs menace quand même des
positions à long terme ils menacent les
blancs menace d'améliorer leur position
roi 2 peut-être pour préparer f3 puis
pour préparer peut-être g4 plus tard
ou f3 peut-être eurois gf2 mètres des
tours
enfin voilà il ya toute possibilité
d'amener le cavalier peut-être plus au
centre alors on peut aussi une menace
bien sûr c'est qu'à lieu de khalef 4
tout simplement ça ça a l'air très fort
si on permet cavalier e 2 même le coup
des noirs qu'on va voir marche plus
parce que cavaye f4 et tout est attaqué
la tour et le fou donc il faut jouer et
6 maintenant voilà si on permet
cavaliers de regarder dans cette
position si on avait permis cavalia 2
juin couche pas assis sous n'importe
quoi maintenant hurricanes f4 et tout
est attaqué c'est terminé voilà donc la
f6 qui paraît logique regarder parce
qu'après puis on prend f6 g36 fouet f4
attaque le pion c'est cet accord c'est
important puisque ici les noirs menace
quand même car les proches 4 le plus que
j'ai trouvé ton cloud et c'est ce qu'ils
font cavalier prend h4 alors là la
question qu'on peut se poser c'est
pourquoi pas pour les blancs ici faux
procès sept
c'est possible vous prend ses 7 est tout
à fait possible
qu'est ce qui se passe ici surtout
prince et 7
les noirs pourrait jouer ici bas plein
conte possible en fait tout est bon que
vous tour g7 ont peu joué fou j'ai
quatre jeux pourquoi pas qui arrive 3
suivi de la patrie les biens qui avaient
pour l'instant ici mais tout le set
c'est bien mon tour je sais que c'est
bien parce que sans doute ont joué en
attaque le fou fou fou bouge on revient
à angers 6 probablement et après on joue
à quatre voix là et là on on éclaircit
la position sans doute c'est bien pour
les noirs puisque en fait on a éliminé
un pion de doublé contre un pion des
blancs voilà tout simplement
voilà donc c'est très simple faux f4
donc il faut pas que les blancs mais sur
les blancs ont intérêt à garder ses
pions de doubler ici et essayer de
prendre le plus lâche 5 et d'avoir un
petit avantage allait droit faut pas
oublier que c'est là que sajoo 1 depuis
le début donc f3 ici pour les blancs en
f3 est intéressant il des f3 bah c'est
de jouer euros m2 voilà on enlève le
vis-à-vis ça obligera le cas via bouger
et on va attaquer ce curage 5 quai
faible c'est la faiblesse blanche
regardez isolé c'est le fameux voyait on
a trois îlots donc on a une cible ici
notamment sa nature attaquer mais celle
là si tu auras chien terminé les
attaquer on peut envisager de doubler
les tours tours h 2e tour à shehata qui
on peut tout faire le siège tour des
huit très bien un tour des huit on
élimine il vaut mieux cette tour joue
pas donc tout quand on est une pièce qui
joue pas si on peut l'éliminer par
rapport une pièce actif c'est mieux
bref deux tours prend cavale et prend
c'est normal alors pourquoi car les
premiers partants reprend mais parce que
carsen très certainement veut recycler
son cavalier en trois alors le problème
de cavalli prend sait aussi que le
footsie s'attaque à deux méthodes pour
l'instant il ya le cavalier h4
qu'attaquer faut pas oublier d'accord
donc cavalier 5 logique
à noter que j'ai 3 est bien protégé par
le fou il ya pas de problème tourache un
mois là car c'est n'a pas peur de fou
prend à deux ils attaquent h5 d'accord
donc les noirs prennent quand même à 2
et là on peut se poser la question qui
s'y passe sur b3 parce que b 3 ans ferme
le fou et ensuite qu'à glisser trois le
gagne mais b3 ne marche pas il
simplement on joue fougue et un essai de
est attaquée d'accord et si on joue
cavalier ou 3
pour protéger ces deux simplement
cavaliers prendre cavaliers roi ou
reprend et puis il faut prince et 2
c'est terminé les noirs al'avantage donc
non on peut pas jouer b3 ça ne marche
pas cette fois le foot rend à 2 ici
marche mais il faut toujours avoir ça en
tête quand on joue ce genre de coup tout
proche 5,2 carsen donc ça y est on a
pris le pion donc là bilan des courses
on se retrouve dans la position je
dirais fondamentale delà de cette
ouverture c'est à dire qu'ici quatre
pions dont un doublé face à deux est ici
deux pions contraint donc en termes de
pions pur les blancs sens moins bien
simplement le pion à 7 et attaquer les
deux pions contre eux c'est quasiment un
pion passé potentiel et les blancs
peuvent pénétrer sur la septième ou le
huitième faire des échecs et à les
affaiblir sa sis à sa tombe
l'avantagé va être énorme donc c'est les
noirs qui malheureux qui enfin
malheureusement non mais c'est les noirs
qui sont sous pression dans cette
position ayant malheureusement donc ici
x 6 il revient car ce n 26 pour protéger
le cavalier 5 qui est sans doute sous sa
meilleure case c'est problème c'est
qu'il faut garder une bonne cadres alors
là on peut se poser la question de ce
qui se passe sur fou prend ses sets ça a
l'air bon il faut prendre ces sept là
faux procès sept que se passe-t-il sur
fond princesse est tout à fait tout à
fait jouable
à noter que c'est pas très très graves
pour les noirs c'est pas une mauvaise
nouvelle
absolue puisque on a trois pions contre
2 est ici deux contre un c'est un
premier point
le deuxième point c'est que sa force
échange des tours tours h6 tournage 6
hélas la tour
obligé de prendre six cavaliers prend
finale de pièces mineurs avec pas
davantage vraiment là les deux pions
deux contre un il ya les tours en moins
ici bon ben c'est un pion passé qui
voilà qui sera contrebalancée par un
pion possible autre côté donc c'est pas
s'il faut garder l'avantagé
positionnelle et c'est pas comme ça
qu'on va le faire donc il joue plus
précis car scène il joue g4 voilà j'ai
quatre on bouge le cavalier force et
donc la case h si ce ne sera plus ne
sera plus attaquer donc le coup c'est
calais des six fois empêché maintenant
faut penser cette puisqu'on peut plus
changer les tours mais non d'accord donc
ici maintenant regarder tour h7 continue
de faire pression sur le pion faible ici
alors si ça ça tombe tout seul mais
attention parce que la tour le cavalier
ne sera obligé de bouger de ce qu'il est
attaqué et à tous qui tombe après un an
qu'il faut absolument faire quelque
chose donc la jolie ont regardé up même
astuce calais cette très jolie très
jolie parce que c'est la même idée sur
fou prend ses sept tours h6 talent le
fou contre le plus actif et sirois g7
roi fuite et la tour est éliminé si la
tour est éliminé deux contre un et ici 3
contre 2 bon y'a plus rien aux cavaliers
3 tranquillement qu'on empêche l'échangé
des tours cette tournée sur les plus
actives que la tour j'ai 6 ans comme ça
aussi qu'il faut noter si les échanges
sont intéressants pour le noir c'est
intéressant d'échanger une tour peu
active face à une tour active pour les
blancs non voilà trois des huit protège
simplement le pion c7
regardez comme la défense des noirs et
précises y siens cavaliers f5
amélioration de la position du cavalier
à noter que la prise ici serait
sanctionné par probablement b puis on
prend tout simplement et saper une pièce
puisque la taux est attaqué et le
cavalier ces cinq points c'est l'heure
pour un homme de jouer là la position de
la berlinoise la position de défense
alors elle consiste à jouer ces cinq ici
regardez ce pion
va jouer contre ce fou et on met les
pions sur noir on va jouer b6 roi ses
8,3 bessette ce roi protège très très
bien cette forteresse et vous allez voir
que c'est fondamental car les g3 il
revient ici car scène ils travaillent
ils travaillent cavale et g3 je peux
menacé de venir par exemple en âge 5
pour faire pression sur m 6
je peux jouer fou des deux fous ces 3 %
qu'attaquer m6 pourquoi pas mais je peux
aussi venir à eux quatre attaquants
c'est cinq attaquants m6 aussi tout ça
il faisait bon ceci dit il ya aussi des
f-5 qui simplifierait la position mais
on aura un pion pas si l'attention
qu'elle g3 donc quand même possible
voilà cavaliers ou 5
à noter que lecavalier en venant ici bas
permet à la tour d'attaquer ses 7 mai
ils bouchent l'action du fou donc voilà
il ya toujours qu'une seule pièce qu'à
taxer cette il ya un défenseur tout va
bien tu auras je suis tes chèvres
pourquoi pas pas forcément le plus
précis ici tout rage suite c'est pas mon
entourage suite échec bon évidemment il
ya la huitième ici donc on peut venir
affaiblir les pions peut-être tout quand
on pose la question aux rois voir le
coût d'un land c'est à dire tour g8 et
la regarde et astuces de carcelle très
joli après ce tour h8 fou prend et
maintenant si les noirs prennent à
schwyz où prend et 6 échecs et je
récupère donc sa force
la réponse des noirs f prend d'accord et
maintenant tour h5 haye
alors est ce que est ce que hollande
avait prévu ça
voyez ça perd le pion alors évidemment
si on perd le pion la simple
compensation ça va être très dur et
regarder un magnifique défense d'un
nombre énorme mais alors ça va nous
amener très très loin donc c'est une
partie d'anthologie fou prend g4
extraordinaire sacrifice de fou sans
quoi c'est foutu c'est à dire lawrence
cannon avait tout prévu surtout rage
suite au rejet vite je ne sais pas
puisque on a vu que la 6e il avait raté
quand même une combine donc on sait
jamais on pourra le savoir que plus tard
un cil en parlait ici et encore si on
croit ce qu'il dit je sais pas mais fou
projet 4 c'est quand même énorme vous
allez voir maintenant la partie va
rentrer dans des eaux tout à fait
inconnu donc là les blancs bien
évidemment on va pas prendre cinq
puisque sinon bon ben la position après
touré suite attaque le pion f3 la
position sera équilibré voilà donc
surtout prend 1,5 touré fuite bon donc
là car scène prend le fou il dit bon
mais je vais essayer de gagner avec
tours et cavaliers alors évidemment la
suite c'est tout reprend g4 j'élimine le
pion passé fin fonds très importants
émission il faut le faire tout de suite
et la tour prend le sec très bien donc
c'est l'heure pour le plan là qu'on a
cité tout à l'heure b6 d'accord et après
quelques atours h4 petit bilan des
courses les pillant les pièces ici sont
centralisées j'ai quatre pions contre 2
mai sur la même elle j'ai pas pu on
passait donc pour eux pour pouvoir
prétendre gagner il faut quand même plus
ont passé un moment donné si vous voulez
hein c'est ça le problème parce que tour
alors faut savoir que touré cavaliers
contre tours ces parties nulles il faut
le savoir ça ce qui est pas la même avec
touré fou contre tours d'ailleurs vous
avez évidemment le philidor 2014 la
réédition du traité de philidor que je
vous invite à évidemment forcément à
alliant parce que philidor c'est le
grand ancêtre le champion du monde
officieux du xviiie siècle le grand
ancêtre du jeu d'échecs dans le monde et
en france en particulier
avait analysé déjà la position touré fou
contre tours mais là c'est tout cavalier
contre tours et là faut savoir que celle
là elle est nul on peut pas y a pas de
forçage de gains alors que tours est fou
contre tout rebond la plupart ça peut
être nul aussi mais c'est la plupart du
temps ça peut gagner parce que il ya des
c'est très difficile à défendre
vous avez d'ailleurs car celle qui a
gagné une partie touré fou contre tours
contre ce vide l'air dans un blitz
mémorable mémorable d'un championnat du
monde de blitz à moscou que je vous
invite aussi à voir et l'analyse de
philidor qui quand même date de 300 ans
et qui est toujours valable c'est tout à
fait extra royaux deux tours h6 donc là
pourquoi pas en fait là les noirs
maintenant vont attendre un peu ce que
font les blancs on va voir c'est pas
simple pour les bains de trouver un plan
b 3 alors ici les les blancs vont avoir
pour idée alors ils jouent b3 pourquoi
v3b d'avoir pour avoir une case de
de sauvegarde du roi blanc parce que sur
des échecs perpétuel où va le roi si on
n'a pas joué b3 c'est un peu embêtant
n'allait 1 à 2 bon bref
tôt ou tard on va vouloir envie ne m en
métro n'y a pas que ça c'est qu'on va
vouloir jouer avec les blancs c4 pour
mettre le cavalier en d5
pourquoi fatah question c'est 7 sinon
comment passer c'est ça le problème
c'est comment essayer de casser sympa ce
que le roi est là il protège tous donc
si voilà tout est protégé c'est très dur
c'est quasi impossible d'aller à ta
question là on va pas trop comment on
pourrait faire donc même d'autant plus
qu'il va sans doute revenir à 6 avec
laurent bessette lecavalier pourra
jamais attaqué cette case venir ces cinq
baies cas tout est pris à moi de venir
en belgique mais il ya un fait même pas
il ya le cavalier donc on peut pas avec
tous les cavaliers attaque elles veulent
la casa 6 donc la seule case qu'on peut
attaquer à la base de la forteresse c6
le pion ses sept pour attaquer cette
case
il faut mettre le calice soit en d5 soit
en bessin en bessin comme on a dit qu'on
allait sans doute joué à 6 mon bébé 5
c'est pas triste figure
s'il ya que des cinq attaquants ça et
forçant les noirs bouger faut les forcer
à bouger posséder affaibli en 3d 7,3 des
deux rois ces six soirées tranquilles il
va se mettre derrière sa forteresse
calais c3 en écho me se presse pas il ya
déjà on prépare calais des cinq d'accord
suivi de ces quatre et il consolide et
puis tours 7
il faut faire attention à 6 on a là bas
on a parlé tout à l'heure à 6 mais déjà
on enlève la case bay 5-1 et comme le
roi donc tard sera en baisse est tout ça
est très très solide n y voit la cc le
problème et ses problèmes de cette
structure de pions de la défense de
berlin et c'est pour ça que les
ordinateurs ont beaucoup de mal à
l'analyse et parce que pour eux en
termes stricts et bon c'est pas c'est
vrai que c'est d'un point de vue
strictement visuel c'est juste il ya
quand même tour et cavaliers 1 contre
tout rebond lecavalier ça vaut 3 donc 3
+ 2 ça fait 5
et là il y en a que quatre donc non la
avantage blanc clairement et avantages
blanc c'est sûr maintenant l'avantagent
blanc on sait bien mais est-ce que ces
gagnants les ordinateurs souvent ici
justifie cette position avec genre plus
en plus deux bons mais plus ou plus 2
c'est presque gagnant
mais en fait vous allez voir c'est pas
si clair c'est même pas clair du tout
tour 4 tours h deux échecs 3 c1
voyez donc là il ya des échecs tourache
un échec voilà roi b2 qu'on justifie le
coup b3 regardez comme les noirs vont
éviter d'affaiblir leur position sans
raison il n'avance pas leurs pions un
ses pions sont doublés donc si on avance
le plan b 5
on se crée des faiblesses ses 5 et
surtout ces cinq nouvelles faiblesses et
avec ses sept tours h6 on revient à 6 on
empêche un échec éventuel de la tour
alors là les blancs veulent aller en
dessin qui peuvent pas je peux et tenter
tour le 5
parce que là peut-être tourner si ces
gens pêche aux cavaliers des cinq donc
de toutes façons pour jouer le cas l'un
des cinq tôt ou tard on va jouer ces
quatre là toute la manoeuvre de carsen
va consister à faire sa cavale et d un
don g6 attentes toute attente cavaliers
ou trois je veux venir un des 5
encore une fois la seule faiblesse c'est
sa tour h 6 tours 7
ça y est on met la tour sur la faiblesse
regardez d'accord tour h2 et j'empêche
c4 pourquoi pas
tours 6 évidemment ça permet tour aux
six échecs bon se parera bessette ça
change pas grand chose à fêter les rois
ces trois ans petite manoeuvre
il se dit ouais je peux peut-être aussi
venir en d3 jouer c4 mais c'est chaud
parce que si je viens des trois c4
peut-être les noirs peuvent venir en b2
j'attaque le pion puis après
revenir ici simplement ici ici le
cavalier bougeant ses 7 il va y avoir
des échecs partout et le roi venir en
être obligé de venir en a trois mais si
le roi bien à 3 il peut y avoir des
menaces de math b 5 b 4 échecs 3,4 torah
de maths j'ai pas si je me fais
comprendre on va le voir tout à l'heure
mais si le sur la colonne à il peut y
avoir des maths aussi pour les blancs
donc c'est pas si simple pour les blancs
de cacher le roi et parce qu'il faut
jouer ces quatre cas les des cinq tours
e7 en cachant le roi parce que sinon on
se prend des échecs un perpétuel quoi
donc tout ça est compliqué tour h4 à
jouer vont à b2 on prépare ses quatre
tours h2 j'empêche ces quatre voiliers
tout est là pour accabler desseigne mais
non puisqu'on a joué tours 6 donc on
peut jouer cavalier des cinq attaquants
c7
alors là la menace c'est très clairement
tour hausse est maintenant au tour des
deux magnifiques coups j'attaque le
cavalier on est d'accord je peux pas
jouer ces quatre avec les blancs puisque
les ja clouage donc là c'est un coup
voyez donc la calle des cinq bien mais
voyez c'est pas si simple de pouvoir
jouer le cavalier sans jouer c'est 4 il
aimerait bien qu'arsène parce que ici
ils voient bien un siège ou c4 il se
prend d échec donc qu'il peut pas cacher
le roi facilement sans donc sans risque
et d
de se faire mater lui-même parce que
peace and b 4 échecs 3-4-3 de maths
c'est chou d'où l'idée aussi à 6 1 600
euros à 4 il peut pas venir en b 5 alors
tour des deux attaques
alors donc ayem 6 to have 2 3 ses trois
taux f4 câble et 4 à noter un qui n'a
pas peur ici je peux revenir juste ici
n'a pas peur de calais desseigne
puisqu'il va faire sans doute échec
bouger puis va revenir en d2 c'est la
même donc câblées aux quatre ils
prennent leur temps tourache quatre
coups d'attentes kalyev deux tours age
ii revient la même position pour m6 ils
essayent carsen de d'essayer de se jouer
cette main 900 jouer ces quatre mois on
va voir qui va t'arriver être sûrs il va
se résoudre à jouer ses quatre tours h7
calais des trois tours h3 clouage on
peut pas bouger déjà pas des 200 tours
échec tour f2 évidemment faux pas
échangé un si vous échangez roi
cavaliers de pions rencontre tout ça là
ça ça va perdre assez sur les blancs
bonbons avancés avec trois cavaliers
vont étouffer le roi noir ils vont gober
les pions et à la fin ils m'ont offert
une dame tourache quatre c4
ça y est c'est leur manque car scène se
résout à jouer ses cartes il aurait pu
le faire depuis longtemps
voilà maintenant orient à noter que il
joue c4 au moment où les noirs peuvent
pas le harceler le roi puisqu'elle a
tourné le dos alors maintenant il va
jouer sans doute cavaliers quatre câbles
et des 5
si les blancs peuvent échanger les tours
si c'est bien donc avalé des 5
après on peut jouer tour deux tours 7
et les noirs peuvent pas s'opposer à la
manoeuvre donc il va falloir tôt ou tard
qu'ils avance ses pions donc c'est ça
c'est ça qui peut donner des chances ou
blanc tour h33 ces deux tours h7
j'empêche tour c est ici qu amélie b 2
se pressent pas à carcen au regard des
incas cavaliers 2 pourquoi calais b deux
caïds et un caillou 3 ou cali c3 et
khalid et 5,6 passes par oc f4 pourrait
mais en passant par arcat il se prend
tous rêvent 7
ici regardez si on joue khalef quatre
tours fc est et on ne peut pas venir là
puisqu'elle tour derrière bon donc ça
oblige et dans ce cas là d'ailleurs
c'est pas simple comment sortir de ça il
faudra avancer le roi mais on a vu que
si on avance le roi se prend d échec si
on perd le pion b3 ça va être nul aussi
parce que si on perd le pion b3 avec les
blancs bas derrière bessengue le pion c4
est éliminé et comme on l'a dit ouri
cavaliers contre tours ça a fait nul pas
oublier ça en tête regardons faut garder
les pions au moins cavalier b2 tourache
cinq tours deux tours g5 coup d'attendre
toujours calé dec leurs attaques
regardez le plan c'est le même un des
cinq seuls les noirs maintenant voit que
la manoeuvre
ces trois des cinq ou ou trois femmes
surtout ces trois des cinq est imparable
donc si cette manoeuvre est imparable
c'est l'heure pour les noirs de faire
quoi d'éliminer ses deux pions c'est ça
l'idée des noirs ici
il faut initier depuis on si ses deux
pions sont éliminés on se connaît des
périodes plus ou passera les noirs et
les blancs ont sans doute les moyens
mais touré cavaliers d'aller prendre les
pions restants mais pas terme at c'est
bien le problème car elle et ses trois
attaques b5
si les noirs prennent c'est pas une
bonne idée c'est pas une bonne nouvelle
puis on prend c'est pas du tout c'est
pourquoi parce que après puis on prend
ce pion là n'est plus échangeables par
des pions or la tour pourra jamais
arriver le gagner on le défend avec le
roi puis avec un cavalier et après on va
faire des manoeuvres on va gober un va
réussir à gommer les trois pions qui
reste ce pion sera une probable donc il
faut surtout pas prendre ici en c4 ce
serait une grossière faut garder le
dynamisme il ne faut prendre ici que
quand on est sûr de pouvoir prendre le
pion qui le peuvent de nouveau le pion
c4 donc soit avec avec le roi qui sera
en position supérieure par exemple mais
s'il ne sais pas ça regardez la défense
cette forteresse est très très forte
simplement on joue ces six mois la
renvoyer les blancs ont forcé les noirs
à avancer ce faisant ils sont légèrement
plus faible bon c'est pas non plus la
fin du monde
puisque cette forteresse reste très
forte au fait tu vois c'est ça le
problème
alors maintenant le nouvel faiblesse bon
c'est plus trop ces six parce que c'est
difficile de ces six parce qu'il
faudrait le cavalier peut pas venir
vraiment à ces impies sur abc ce qu'ils
attaquent le cavalier peut pourra pas
venir à 1,5 attaquer ces six avec la
tour qui attaqueraient aussi puisque 5
et - secure que la casse des scènes qui
ont eu à l'heure qu'on pouvait protéger
avec un pion là il n'y a pas de piquant
protéger donc faut protéger tous avec la
tour tout un attaquant si pape c'est pas
jouable sans compter qu'il ya des échecs
perpétuel ou quasi perpétuel la sueur
sur le râble ans donc la faiblesse ici
aller où les pensées 6 elle est plutôt
assez 5
voilà ce pion est un tout petit peu
faible bon alors là c'est ce que fait
400 ha qui met l'accent dessus alors à
noter qu'ici tout re 5 marche pas
puisqu'il ya qu'elle ait des six échecs
ton contours toile 5 ko l'ifsi ce petit
travail attaque la tourbe on sait rien
toucher 5
je garde un oeil sur voilà et maintenant
tour cet échec forcera b61 n'y a pas de
problème et la cale aider cet échec
à noter que ce coup attaque le roi et le
pian c5 le coup suivant et forcé pour
les blancs puisque enfin on vous
remarquez on pourrait envisager de venir
en ce 7 mai ça alors est ce que ça
marche
oui c'est bon pour les c'est bon pour
les blancs on peut le voir tient alors
sirois c'est cette variante
alors on peut envisager imaginons qu est
ce que ça va qu'est ce qui se passe sur
cavaliers prince et 5 mai sur six ans
rejouera des six cavaliers chèque au rap
cavale et prend et ça paie ça peut
gagner pour les blancs même si sans
doute gagnant puisque en cas de prise
ici prise et se payant sera jamais
prenable câble est supérieur pour rien
donc ça gagne donc là et ça ça a l'air
ça a l'air très bon il reste quoi il
reste trois des huit mais là on peut
faire tourner cet échec froissé 8 pour
rester au contact de la tour le cavalier
est attaqué ainsi que la tour est là ah
oui un coup intermédiaire cavaliers aux
6es en cas d'échec simplement autour des
2 juste à temps rien autre coup si
j'attaque le cavalier par exemple par
tours de 5 alors simplement tours 7
et le roi ne peut pas venir attaquer la
tour donc probablement gagnant aussi
d'envoyer ses choix donc son cahier des
sept noms faugeron à 5 tours 4 sur
protection de la case c4 et maintenant
c'est leur échec france est un échec
rendait deux échecs comme on l'a dit
tout à l'heure on l'a dit depuis un
moment alors à noter un jeu
que regardez un c'est ce qu'on disait
tout à l'heure déjà sur la colonne ci
sur échec le roi a essayé de se cacher
alors comment il pourrait faire alors à
noter que bon on peut regarder sur roy
ces trois ici bas simplement on fait
encore touché 3 et suroît bon pour
regarder servi alors ce roi c3 dont j'ai
trois échecs
roye b 2 par exemple et évidemment sur
roy b2 on peut pas venir se cacher en a
trois parce que c'est matt lorsqu'on dit
tout à l'heure même si le roi était
là-bas sur échec ici roi à quatre tours
à deux maths c'est le problème c'est que
pour ça les blancs résister longtemps je
veux c'est 4 c'est qu'on peut plus
cacher des échecs après donc alors on
est obligé de partir et c'est le roi par
les pions qui nous permettent
d'envisager la victoire ses deux pions
là ils sont en danger par rapport au roi
noir lee qui quand même et actif aussi
oui c'est très difficile à ding essayer
de garder des chances de victoire en
fait c'est ça le problème
échec alors à noter un collier blanc
attaque le pion c5 ici on a des deux
depuis tout à l'heure un donc ici
maintenant
échec re 1 et là maintenant c'est
l'heure pour les noirs d'envisager ils
le font tout de suite b prince et quatre
au bon moment le roi est éloigné voilà
il très loin la tour en plus la pêche de
bouger on prend alors maintenant si tout
reprend simplement tour g3 et c'est fini
on va d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'on va voir
d'ailleurs c'est pas tout à fait fini on
va voir s'est passé pas si c'est pas si
nette tout reprend ses 4 regardez
magnifique défense d'un land
alors évidemment si on joue ici tour
b26 faisable il va y avoir calé princes
et saint qui protège ici donc j'ai trois
attaques le plan b 3 donc là attention
si on regardait des chances de gain
qu'on me l'a dit il faut protéger ce
plan si je fais tout reprend ses 5
imaginons tient d'accord alors dans ce
cas là roye b 4 on est d'accord attaque
la tour bon allez protégé par le
cavalier mais surtout le pion b3 et
perdu voilà et si on élimine ce pion
qu'on me l'a dit touré cavaillé contre
tours ça fait nul il faut le savoir amis
n'ont donc tout rejet 3 on 3 du cavalier
et on protège on se dit mais là c'est
bon j'ai réussi à garder mon pions alors
c'est vrai or le problème la commune ce
pion c'est que on va voir c'est que
hollande quand même a quand même prévu
qu'il pouvait quand même le prendre
comment il va faire il joue d'abord à b5
il se met au contact du cavalier ça va
forcer sur ton j'ai simple cahier de
bouger mais s'il y avait les bouches qui
protégera pas clair donc ici car scène
joue tour ces deux
alors il peut prévoir par exemple
devenir en d1 c'est un b 2 quelque chose
comme ça mais est ce qu'il aura le temps
à 5 à 5 c'est pas mal aussi à 5
ça peut menacer tour la cavale et bouge
à 4 et le pion est éliminée 6 j'élimine
ce pion comme l'indicé nul donc là il
reste 3 f 2 tours h3 regarde il reste au
contact
pas de problème alors qu'est ce qui se
passe sur tours g5 ici c'était sans
doute aussi jouable tour g5
dans ce cas là on joue ah oui il ya une
astuce c'est qu'on jour et lecavalier a
eu six attaques la tour et en menace
cavaliers ou quatre échecs et je protège
le pion et c'est une mauvaise nouvelle
pour les noirs donc un homme préfère
jouer tourache trois tours c'est un sa
tour c'est un coude attente il attend de
voir ce que vont faire les noirs
évidemment ici un problème pour les
blancs les noirs se réjouit web etc à
tour ses quatre chiens qu'on a trois
tours à quatre rois b2 je prends à 5
alors là tout est protégé et là on a le
pion de plus bien clair et là c'est pas
net panet et c'est sans doute gagner
pour les blancs faut faire attention
mayroy b4 quand même en d4 pourquoi mais
j'attaque le pion b3 maintenance cavaler
peut pas bouger s'il bouge prouve c'est
perdu d'accord 3 2 ils ramènent le roi
maintenant en défense il a mené plus tôt
d'ailleurs
et là regardez là pas peur allende
simplement pour ces trois c'est pire et
oui c'est pire parce que là alors si on
bouge de cavaillon père le cube et 3
même si on fait chier avec mon père le
cube étroit et il reste
et surtout reprendre tour up
regardons cette variante tour par tour
roy prend d'accord et là regardez le roi
peut pas avancer
donc si par exemple le coup comme le roi
des huns pour essayer de se dire je vais
essayer de me rapprocher de ce piment
mais simplement ça marche pas puisque
ici on joue d'abord oib quatre attaques
le cavalier de calais doit bouger et on
prend le pion métro voire même on joue à
quatre alors ce qu'avaient les chèques
qu'on prend b3 c'est terminé vous savez
comme cavani contre roye ça peut pas
maté voilà donc tour ces trois forces
quasiment la suite cavaliers des trois
échecs
ra prend tour à 1 vous allez voir que
carsen continue c'est magnifique mais on
sait que c'est nul la partie mais n'a un
an d'un réussi à gober les deux pions
dangereux quoi les blancs n'ont pas de
ya pas de plan de gains donc c'est
extraordinaire comme défense parce que
fallait envisager tout ça depuis le
début qu'à varroase quatre cavaliers 2,3
b5 protège les pions mais vous allez
voir que tourbe est un échec trois c4 on
va avancer vous allez voir que les
blancs implacablement vont prendre les
points de plus attac la tour on peut
aller un peu vite maintenant c'est pas
la peine d'y passer par des bonds faut
être précis avec les blancs on va quand
même
lord ekomy joue quand même hein si on
est un championnat du monde bon la
limite le seul qui peut gagner c'est les
noirs c'est à dire que tous les
cavaliers contre ça gagne pas mais les
deux pions là s'il y en a un qui fait
dame touré pions contre tours or là
aussi la position de philidor le
philidor 2014 je vous invite parce que
philidor là aussi dès le xviiie siècle à
analyser la position touré pions contre
tours avec la fameuse position de
philidor extraordinaire donc imaginer
comment philidor pouvait déjà vous
démontrer qu'on pouvait gagner cette
position alors position de leader on
peut la gagner ou faire nul et mais il
faut connaître la position qui permet de
gagner de faire nul voila et parfois ça
se joue à qui a le trait voiliers et
faut faire attention cavale et ses trois
échecs
donc faut être précis mais bon à ce
niveau là là ici aussi que la position
sera nulle parce que le roi si vous
voulez de voir le pion et on peut
justement obtenir la position de leader
mais les noirs peuvent gagner la sepsie
eux quand le pion de plus qu'ils peuvent
faire dame trois des six donc faire
attention mais howard et voilà ça y est
le pion à 3 et perdu peut pas venir en a
deux le cavaly évidemment et la tour
permette de gober les pions cavalli
prend tranquillement échec tac échec en
les trois échecs comme les c3 tu auras
300g trois échecs en ses sept tours j'ai
quatre tours h7 bon c'est instructif
parce que ça permet de voir comment de
gober les pions avec une pièce de plus
évidemment il faudra à chaque fois
prendre quasiment avec lecavalier
parce que et avec prend en étant protégé
de la tour voire dur et du roi aussi
pour éviter que la tour adverse échange
la tour faute si on veut gagner il faut
éviter les changes de tours bien entendu
il faut prendre les pions avec la pièce
mineurs la plus faible
ici le cavalier échec france est
regardée il avance le roi ici sans qu'un
échec soit possible au contact du pion
3,17 un v6
regardez comme ils gagnent du terrain
tout ici évidemment les noirs ont
intérêt à se mettre en position de faire
des échecs très long très pénible face
aux adversités chèque
alors évidemment si la les noirs jouent
un coup comme le roi des six il y aurait
tout à tour j'ai six échecs
trois des cinq on pourrait prendre ici
puisque en cas d'échec simplement via c7
et tout est protégé
natori protégé par le roi et le cavalier
protégé par la tourte donc on va obtenir
la position allemande lâche le pion pas
de problème roy prend et voilà on est la
fameuse position touré cavaillé contre
tours et vous jouez
or la règle c'est ici c'est 70 coups
vous allez voir ils vont pas jouer 70
coups ils vont quand même tenté il va
tenter car ce n est quand même faire mal
ce petit et itil voilà il joue tac up
tories tchèques
la plongée si évidemment il évite les
changes le tour si on veut c'est de
gagner un rang des cons mais on met la
tour loin du roi c'est pour pouvoir le
harceler d'échec un ici bon regarder et
sur le coup calais c'est trop on ne peut
pas venir faire échec ici on pourrait
venir là éventuellement mais on sait pas
le but on essaie de garder loin et on
fait des échecs que si on est vraiment
en position supérieure échec alors le
problème du cac a laissé ça c'est qu'il
peut pas avec le fou on peut avec un fou
on peut à la fois avance et contrôler
des cases et puis barré avec le fou avec
le cavalier ses futurs auriez pour
barrer un échec on est obligé de mettre
car il ya deux classes du roi donc faut
que la tour le protège donc du coup
c'est beaucoup plus instable que ça
permet pas de gagner en fait voilà qu'à
liège 4 d'orages sur un tour j'ai six
échecs et des 3 voilà bon maintenant
mais si lecavalier là ils protègent plus
il ne contrôle plus il empêche les
chèques certes mais contre le plus de
gaz permettant de repousser le renoir
parce que là le plan des blancs
éventuellement se serait d'amener le roi
noir à la bande sur un truc pour essayer
de menacer des maths mais voyez que
c'est extrêmement difficile et c'est
impossible en fait voilà on peut pas le
forcer quoi un tac
hélas ici car scène joue tour c1 et
après tout reprend cavale et prend la
partie nuls magnifique défense de la
langue
donc c'est tout à fait extra alors à
noter que tout ça
anand a dû envisager que c'était nul
depuis ce fameux coup ici dans cette
position au 31e coup alors que la partie
va jusqu au 122e coup et vous imaginez
ça fait quand même presque 80 81 coup ça
fait 80 coût 80 coups de distance à 81
coups de distance
un homme voit que cette position est nul
c'est extra position nuls avec le
magnifique sacrifice fou quand j'ai
quatre et un ans se disent ah tiens et
très probablement il a raison ça tient
on l'a vu le seul plan des blancs pour
c'est de gagner les oblige à s'affaiblir
suffisamment pour que leurs pions soit
éliminée et donc tour est calé contre
tours ça fait nul et là on les grands
maîtres battent les ordinateurs puisque
c'est une des rares position où les
ordinateurs ne ne savent pas évalué que
en fait
leur leurs estimations ne va pas jusqu'à
81 coup voilà les ordinateurs sont
limitées en gros si vous voulez à
quelque chose comme 15/2 coup c'est à
dire sept coups coin sept coups cette
hui coup à lady coûts au maximum
du coup c'est déjà énorme et en fait
parce que les possibilités sont
exponentielles ça va ça va très très
vite
magnifique défendre d'un an d'une
victoire un peu psychologique un amende
dans cette partie peut-être qu'il savait
parfaitement jouer cette finale il a
peut-être travailler là peut-être jouer
cette finale face à des ordinateurs
plein fois pour s'entraîner et savoir
comment annuler à tous les coups c'est
tout à fait envisageable donc voir avec
des entraîneurs et nous puisqu'on a dit
les ordinateurs sont pas sont pas
forcément au top sur ce type de position
voilà donc la défense de berlin recèle
des secrets
insondable c'est totalement
incompréhensible comme déférence vois la
magnifique égalisation danone dans cette
partie en fin match nul de la norme
puisqu'il est toujours mené dans le
match 1 donc remarquer ici donc alors je
vous mets ici le les parties regardez
donc carsen victoire ici est la deuxième
à nantes égalise et puis donc la sixième
où on l'a vu tout à l'heure à nantes
aurait pu et on envisager de revenir
voir ben ils auraient pu au moins annulé
puis sans doute la gagner assure une
gaffe de gars de carsen bon à part cette
gaffe il était quand même moins bien
donc il faudra qu'ils évitent ce type
d'ouverture c'est ce qu'il a fait dans
la septième est donc là il avait vient
de faire match nul
donc il est toujours mené d'un point
mais il reste saine parti et laura trois
fois les blancs donc tout est encore
jouable
tout est encore jouable pour pour anand
dans ce championnat du monde
car scène allende 2014 merci de nous
avoir suivi sur diagonale tv puis je
donne donc rendez vous à la prochaine
partie de ce championnat du monde
extraordinaire au revoir